おはようございまーす
そんなおはようございますございます
宜しくお願いしますよろしくお願いますはい今日もよろしくお願いますはい
いろいろ言いたいところあるんですねんかあもんですかはい何もです
いや特に大丈夫ですかなんかですかはい相談今日はですね
ズバリはい朝今6時半ごろですけどあれございます
どこに向かってますでしょう時給です
[音楽]
そもさん
つきました
フジッコじゃないですか普通中です富士宮の長をはっきります付随中ですもう入っ
ちゃってる女バー開けないでください
えってどういうことをそっと違うということですおはようございます
3年前の受給
コージツです迷っています開演前の富士急でございますよ調の曲は
聖魔さん
乗っている観覧車だけ
折りになっているドッキ0
imac ず93すごくですね観覧車の突堤の観覧車だけおりになってるらしいんで
今日はそうパターンを目隠ししたのまあ
くださいませはそんなさんも目隠しして患者さんませんですけど3月取ったらそうな
ちゃんの観覧車で木を切りになっているというドッキリやっていきたいとおもいます
シンプルに恋決めてきたんですけど本当にしたも好き
池全部おりになってて安全年的に大丈夫なのかというところとてもホワイト思います
予想はさんにそんな俺のような観覧者
楽しんでいただきましょう上は
[音楽]
me
与沢さん税開演前なんですそんな三者僕画面で目隠ししてません
開演前な人はいないのでますかせなくなるんでパス入っ同じを聞いてくださってどんな
ことが必要なんですね
僕は全赤ティン
設けないでじゃあ一人になっております一人になっちゃうんですけどあー
信じてくっついてくれば絶対大丈夫でっ俺あの本ってないんですかず思ってたらあれば
使っている
平山をずっと走って英語のいるからもいないで安全でさあ空強かった姿高いところ苦手
でしたっけ
そんなふうただ言うパック
誰がいいか
僕らのですに来れずいきましょうはい奢ろう車
やばいです
経済持っての怖いです
[音楽]
うーんちょっと見たね adobe 救われるんじゃないまあ今マジ何も聞こえない
4星人ですかはいずむ
[音楽]
rar ん
さーああああ
アーちゃん my phone ちゃめよどんな違っておりますよどうぞへ
男ほんとついてはマゾ乗ります
なんだえっデンバーきたら
でて
待って聞こえないか大丈夫そうだばをスルー
ええええええ
持った
これからだ上火不安の3
[拍手]
なにこれはっはーがんば座ったことない漢字やだ
このベンチこれベンチ
これペチッかなこれどういうことなんだろうなぁ
待って動いてる
follow 動いてるか
[音楽]
うこっ
よどういうことなんだろうん
ゴロンダモノを見せつけてヤル
[音楽]
ん
んもう始まりますか
始まってる何かやってますん
[拍手]
[音楽]
こんなやブラジャーしましたーーー
かなり高いものところまで来ました今はわかんないと思うんですけど
目隠し取った瞬間めっちゃ濃いと思うんですよね
あとこれ止まります頂上で特別な休暇を頂いて止まります観覧者つまりの中で声と思う
んすよ
さあそろそろ止まると思います
うわぁ高は俺だったら萎えちゃってるね
はぁもなく頂上です
[音楽]
犬のかな俺は
ran
[音楽]
安全のため止まるアナウンスがなっております
マブなんば一旦
なんですかー
ぽっぽぽっぽ待ったねっ
揺れてないん
バッハそんなことないよねベルトついてないけど
ええっ
ベルト続いてないけど大丈夫かではそろそろ電話してみようと思います
java 急遽ばさぞ
私はございません
みなさーん
冷やしてパスワードあ
goo
なんてろくに300
あって a 6239ですよ
違うや5分後になっちゃったよ hey
えっなんか本所電話で相馬さんに電話して目がちとだせようと思ったんですけど
研究をスマホのパスワードが分からなくなってしまいましたいやー
[拍手]
そっちらーんゲイ
そうも3人目楽器とってて言って
よしたし雨ねー
雀荘ん
goo
あれですね
[音楽]
目が薄くなってるねー
amaran
[音楽]
me
a ノーモザ
そのさーん
ね学習へ跳んでください
ていません
これ孫ああっ
[音楽]
ブーブーわー
goo
ua 米直スターマインを通すんと思いどういう状況はこれやっぱ
まいたらまず良いん
県警
月経
品物版カードを覚えて教えてください
ああああああ
一方します720ときましたありがとうございました
そうもどうぞ星さまさんどうですか
きっ
入るいいいいいいいい
聴こえてます
どうですかオリー
ゾークにおりにいる気分はん
にゃんっはいそう何コレ
そんなこれ実はですねこの観覧車も動きません
嘘です
none
ni wa nai
美女
おかえりなさーん
ヤバイっすよはいというわけで相場さんの嘆願しただけ
おりドッキリでしたあーやばい e 6-8バイスで wifi 風がー
第二とあったんですよじゃあもう空にいるみたいな感じ
最初どんな線パーティで開けられてるのかキュリさんも降ってますかんソフトいうかと
かて来ませんぞ沿って
funny クマですよん
海自の動画でしたそれぞれハイあの本当に
follow 改めて入庁かつ5名頑張ってですはい
オペロンちょっと待って
その超できないこれ